[Music]
this practice of the ritual ceremony of
flyers is not a tourist act it is not
a circus act
for us this is a
cultural heritage and a spiritual part
[Music]
my name is víctor garcía and I am one of
the papantla flyers
I started  practicing this dance of the
flyer since I was very young
[Music]
today I am the caporal teacher of the flyer
my responsibility to ski the
group to fulfill everything that is
needed for the success of the ritual the
tradition of the dance of the
flyers originated 600 years ago  In Mesoamerica
it is said that a long time ago in this
region there was a drought, so a child
was chosen to have this vision and
form a group and thus communicate with
the solar deity.
a show in which we ask
permission to climb to the heights the
flying stick where we perform
our good is 23 meters
behind  mind, already being on the heights,
the fifth element rises in this case
I stand up to communicate with the
solar deity
[Music]
the sound that emanates from the flute gives the
indication when they have to
throw themselves
is an inner peace that is felt  at the
moment of descending and an emotion or
joy when we arrived on the ground
this tradition of the flyer was
passed on to me by my grandfather well the
importance of passing this tradition on to
the new generations is that they
agree that they have an identity you
are the future for preservation  of
this ceremony
in culture and traditions have
a beginning but they do not have an end
so I consider that I had a
beginning when I made my first flight
but I have not thought about when I am going to
finish I am going to continue transmitting
this legacy as long as the body endures
[  Music]